another sector of of this industry that
you've been uh somewhat vocal about is
the bitcoin spot etf now for years we
had uh no etf in the united states we
basically had these publicly traded
trusts other jurisdictions around the
world they went ahead and they've
approved etfs etps etns you know the
whole alphabet soup uh and when uh the
new kind of administration came in i
think there's a lot of hope that okay
these people understand bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies and they're gonna be
somewhat sympathetic and kind of push
some forward uh some approvals here we
did get an etf approval just happened to
be a futures-based one versus spot
what's your thoughts on the spot etf is
the futures one good should we be
pressuring regulators to approve a spot
how does that work
uh your last question absolutely we
should be pressuring them to approve a
spot uh it's interesting the um
you you look at what their mission is
uh the mission of the sec and these
other uh federal agencies is to protect
americans right protect investors
and i i get such a kick out of it the uh
you said it i felt the same way i felt
the last administration did have some
champions right hester purse
uh giancarlo brian brooks you know some
people that were really forward thinking
and thoughtful uh but we were running
into a lot of friction with the
the existing
financial uh
services establishment the traditional
uh financial
uh i guess legacy financial institutions
and this new disruptive technology so i
thought we had a change of
administrations just like you brought up
pomp i thought we were going to have
some some new thought coming in and
frankly it's been as difficult or more
difficult and gary gensler is one of the
uh
what uh villains if you will of the uh
of the current uh theater production uh
that is uh uh this administration and
their approach towards uh
cryptocurrencies and other
uh financial instruments in this new
digital age it's uh
you talk about the spot etf uh so they
denied uh scaramucci a well-known name
from new york they denied uh
an application from his group two weeks
ago they denied one from fidelity
and again they say they're protecting
the individual american investors which
is their mission at the sec pomp
but the intellectual
disconnect or the inca intellectual
inconsistency is where does the futures
market get its price from it gets it
from the spot market
so you have to be asking yourself and i
just can't believe and forgive me for
this but i can't believe they think
we're this stupid that uh the average
american investor that is working hard
every day to study this stuff and
understand where it's going and what
they might do they they understand uh
how inconsistent this is uh and now
rather than uh starting to work with us
and we're going to continue to put
pressure on them now they want to take
it a step by uh farther i think uh the
nuns that are lady of grace would sit
farther further can't remember but the
uh
they want to take it a step farther by
changing the definition of an exchange
so that it's not just facilitating a uh
a sale uh facilitating
uh a deal but now it's putting uh
sellers and buyers together think about
that palm if if they actually do the
switch by the way i would argue this is
gary gensler going around the
legislative branch of government because
he knows he doesn't have this authority
but if he can somehow convince people
through a rule-making process that he's
able to expand the sec's jurisdiction
guess what he's writing himself a blank
check to weigh in on every single uh
communication protocol out there
that's why i think it's really important
for members of congress people with
election certificates to get up to speed
and more importantly to lean in and lean
in hard